[Music]
back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings and we
bring you a six-month cbs news
investigation that raises new questions
about how effectively state medical
boards can hold bad doctors accountable
and thereby protect patients this
morning we hear from the for the first
time from an insider who sits on
california's medical board which is
responsible for licensing and
disciplining more than 150 000 doctors
in part one of our two-part series chief
investigative correspondent jim axelrod
looks at the case of a doctor who was
allowed to continue practicing despite
repeated misconduct that the medical
board knew about jim good morning good
morning tony in california a board of 15
people makes these decisions about when
a doctor should lose his or her license
to practice now eight of the 15 are
other physicians
our investigation raised questions about
who that board is protecting the public
or the doctors
i think i was absolutely botched
there's just no other description for it
brandi williams is describing a 2016
surgery she thought would help her get
her confidence back after losing almost
30 pounds williams decided to reward her
hard work with a procedure known as an
abdominoplasty or tummy tuck the
doctor's office is supposed to be a
place of healing and that's not what
this place was for me my name is jason
hellowell to do the surgery brandi chose
dr jason heliwell an ob gyn who also
conducts cosmetic procedures he
practices in this building behind me
right here in bakersfield but brandi
says she only chose him after first
conducting her own research into his
record
i took the business card from his office
which has his medical license number on
it i went home
found out if there were any complaints
against him it was blank
there was no complaints against him we
discovered dr hellerwell had been
disciplined for negligence five years
earlier i was in pain for a year and a
half according to a malpractice lawsuit
williams settled with dr hellowell her
surgery left her with a painful hematoma
that required surgical repair
williams says that pain drove her to
file a complaint about dr hellewell to
the california medical board it's their
job to protect us from doctors who
make mistakes i'm not saying he's not
human we all make mistakes but he made a
whopping mistake when it came to me
what could have been helpful to williams
was knowing another patient had already
reported dr hellowell it's not like
i went to a car dealership and went to
buy a car this is my life six weeks
after delivering her child emily yost
says dr hellewell told her she needed
umbilical hernia surgery and he could do
the procedure in his office
even though emily says it had been
scheduled for the hospital knowing what
i know now i would have switched doctors
immediately okay this is my online
complaint summary yoast sent this
complaint to the california medical
board explaining she had to have an
additional surgery to fix the surgery
that dr hellewell performed
i never got an email that said
hey we'll look into it we're sorry that
happened nothing
nothing happened
but cbs news has learned that while the
medical board dismissed brandie williams
complaint
and never even bothered to contact emily
yost the california medical board had
been investigating dr hellewell the
entire time this 54-page ruling details
a laundry list of misconduct by dr
hellewell dating back to 2013 including
a sexual relationship with a patient
administering toxic dosage of lidocaine
and gross negligence in the treatment of
four patients
investigators concluded hellowell's care
of one patient showed a fundamental lack
of knowledge but in 2018 the california
medical board did not revoke dr
hellewell's medical license
instead they placed him on 42 months
probation with limits on his practice
since the medical board's ruling dr
hellewell has been arrested and charged
with 32 felony counts for a fraudulent
medical billing scheme
his medical license in california
remains active
what does a doctor have to do in
california to lose his or her license
that is a great question
and the answer is i don't know
tj watkins currently sits on the
california medical board he's speaking
out for the first time
is the california medical board doing
its job
absolutely no
cbs news found that since 2015 the
medical board received more than 50 000
complaints against doctors yet they
revoked just 201 licenses
less than one-half of one percent
do you think the way
the medical board functions actually
ends up costing patient lives
there's no question that it costs
patients lives no question no question
dr hellewell declined an interview when
we reached out with questions we never
heard back now as for the medical board
it said the law requires it to
rehabilitate doctors when possible
although the board does tell us it is
currently looking into the criminal
allegations against dr hellowell
tomorrow in part two of our
investigation you will hear more from
our exclusive interview with california
board member t.j watkins who says the
board does allow dangerous doctors to
keep practicing
i think that i'm really looking forward
to hearing what mr watkins has to say i
think it's extraordinary that he's still
sitting on the board he's criticizing
the people that he's working with that's
a big deal and and in very clear and
unambiguous terms he will continue that
tomorrow morning and speaking of
ambiguity i mean there should be
standards for practice and when you
violate those standards your license
should be revoked but no one seems to
know where the line is well a lot of
this comes back to the makeup of the
board now remember you have a 15-member
board majority rules and you've got a
majority of documents so everything sort
of funnels back to that controlling
premise when it comes to how does this
board function how are the women doing
brandy and emily i mean i think you sit
with them and there's this overarching
question of wait a minute
if if the board's not going to protect
us who does exactly so in addition to
all the the suffering and the trauma
there's this question of who's going to
take care of us yeah looking forward to
part two thanks no doubt about